This is an interesting question.
This is from Kevin E.
This is from Kevin from Oregon.
He is a high school math teacher. Nice. >>Cool--and a cross-country skier.
He has a pretty interesting question.
He's asking, "There has been talk within the press and the media about programming
and knowledge of programming becoming a 3rd required literacy of education."
At least in the United States it's very common that you have verbal requirements,
learning how to read and write, and mathematics requirements, learning how to do algebra.
I guess he's asking do you feel that programming could be that 3rd section that's kind of required
and designed into every curriculum everywhere?
I think this is a really interesting question. >>It is interesting.
I think there's definitely a tremendous value for students learning programming early in school.
I think there's a lot of things that in the traditional grade school curriculum--
I'm speaking about the U.S, I don't know much about how that works in other parts of the world--
hopefully they're more forward thinking than America has been.
But what's taught in grade school is--and this actually goes through high school--
is pretty much 1950s curriculum.
It really hasn't changed, and there's a lot of time spent on learning how to do mechanical calculations.
Students are basically learning algorithms for doing division, for solving complex problems
by following mechanical steps, and they're learning how to do this very carefully and precisely--
the kinds of things that computers should be doing,
and it would be much better if students were learning how to think about things algorithmically,
how to think about how to describe the way to solve problems
rather than following steps the way a computer follows them.
I think I'm probably not the one who knows how to redesign our elementary school curriculum,
although it's definitely a good thing to think about.
I think there are great ways to learn about math by doing programming,
and there are programs that are seeking to do that. >>At Euler?
Euler. There's also a project that started at Northeastern doing this.
So I there's a lot of--actual that started at Brown,
I'm forgetting the name of it now. I was just hearing about it earlier today from our field trip to Missoula.
But there are projects that are doing things where the best way to learn about physics
or to learn about math is really to build a simulation yourself.
That's true also learning about lots of things in society like elections or how people interact with eachother.
If students learned about programming when they were in school,
they would understand these things much better than the, I think,
much more difficult ways of understand them as mathematical models.
A lot of it is it's just a systematic way of thinking.
I like the idea of thinking of it as a third branch of literacy
that everyone who wants to function well in the world and understand how things work
really should understand programming.
They don't have to be expert programmers,
but at least enough to be able to understand how things work.
Is there an age requirement at Udacity?
Where are our lawyers? I hope our lawyers aren't watching. >>Maybe we shouldn't answer that.
We have no age requirement.
There are laws in the U.S. about
if you collect an email address from someone what age they can be.
Identifiable information.
We are happy to have all students in the class.
Students that are under whatever legal age the U.S. law would say are--
Well, our content is creative commons licensed.
--yes, can definitely take the class, and we assume anyone tells us that their age is below
whatever the minimum legal is--
But what I'm more interested in is can you be too old?
You can't be too old. I know we definitely have 80-year-olds in the class.
I hope we have a 90-year-old. I haven't heard from one directly yet.
I had a conversation with an 82-year-old. That's cool.
He was following along pretty well.
I think it's great that there's lots of retired people in the class.
I can say my mom is taking the class as well as my dad.
I don't mention their ages. It's under 82, so that's good.
Does anyone have a question they want to ask verbally?
You got a compliment about I hope people are enjoying it as much as we here.
We're having a great time, and a lot of what makes a class work are the contributions of students as well.
That's fantastic. >>And that's very evident on the forums.
Some of the stuff we see on the forums we share around the office.
It's pretty amazing what some of our students do. That's my shout out to our students.
How do programmers make a new programming language?
Okay, yeah. How and why do people make a new programming language.
Why would you need a new programming language?
One of the things I may have mentioned--I don't remember.
All programming languages are exactly as powerful in terms of
once you have the things--and I did talk about in Unit 2
that once you know about if and procedures and variables and arithmetic,
you've got enough to write every possible program.
Every programming language is equally powerful.
They can all write the same exact set of all possible programs.
In a theory class, that's explained more precisely what that means,
but once you have those few basic things, that's really enough to build everything else.
That raises the good question of why are there thousands of programming languages.
There are thousands, and there are people making up new programming languages all time.
There are lots of different reasons to make a new language.
Sometimes it's just for fun, and it's definitely something that you learn a lot from.
I think those of you who take the programming languages class next
will get a sense for how easy it is to change what a language means
and how interesting it is to do that.
There are joke languages too. >>There are. Yeah.
Languages created just to be funny.
That's one reason. There are more serious reasons to create a new language.
All of language design is really a trade off. You're trading off different things.
You're trading off how easy it is to write programs with how fast your programs can fun.
We've chosen to teach 101 in a language that's Python that is designed
where making it easy to write programs is more important than making the programs run fast.
There are other languages, and if you're writing code for, say,
controlling the fighter jet, how fast it takes to make decisions is more important
than how easy it is for the code to write.
You can spend millions of dollars getting the code written. You hope it's correct.
But performance is much more important. That's one trade off.
Another trade off is between how expressive the language is
and how easy it is to write something that doesn't mean what you want it to mean.
Python is quite an expressive language.
It's easy to write things in Python
that seem correct but don't mean exactly what you wanted them to mean.
There are other languages that try much harder to make it so if you write code
and the code runs, it's more likely to mean exactly what you thought it meant.
Those languages do things that make it harder to accidentally write a program
that means something different.
There are lots of different programming languages for both reasons of style and taste,
but there are also some good engineering reasons why we need many different programming languages.
Feel free to ask a question.
Until then we're going to just look through the forums.
Do we have the audio on? >>Audio is on. Oh, I don't have audio on. Sorry.
If someone was talking, would you please repeat the question? I've got to get better at that.